Yes, a thread block contains many threads,
and it's also true that an SM might run more than one block.
On the other hand, a thread block may not run on more than one SM.
By definition, a thread block is run on a single SM.
Now, all the threads in a thread block may cooperate to solve a subproblem.
That's why we have thread blocks.
This last one is false, and it's a bit subtle so let me talk it through.
The key, as I said, all the threads that run on a given SM may cooperate to solve a subproblem,
but in fact you might have multiple thread blocks on an SM,
and by definition threads and different thread blocks should not attempt to cooperate with each other.
And that's why this statement is not the same as the one before it.